the Joe Rogan experience yeah but if you
can get a pig with a human vagina
well that's people [ __ ] sheep right
there's nothing all deal with sheep
supposed to be like real close they say
probably in Pennsylvania - I mean I'm
sure in Pennsylvania carried away when
people get you know again what you said
no options no standards yeah unit yeah
if you found out that no one was looking
we don't [ __ ] sheep because it's gross
they [ __ ] sheep because the Sheep is
that high and right there yeah
what about that poor guy who's the exact
right height for a sheep perfect like I
don't even have to bend my knees at all
the Sheep likes it thank you
who's the victim yeah yeah maybe the
Sheep was like maybe the Sheep keeps
like she keeps nuzzling up against him
like like like Oh Liz oh damn that's
that guy's defense in court he's just
like no but you've got a look at this
video you can't tell me that sheeps not
into this here's a video of me entering
into the pen now look they're all back
towards me backwards yeah they all just
go right one of them is buying I'm
pretty sure juice it's a ridiculous
thing that people [ __ ] animals but
animals [ __ ] people too yeah you know
you ever see dolphins dolphins get a
hold of people I've seen a video that
careers one of the dolphin link came
upon a woman trying to [ __ ] her there
was an article it's the best it's the
best trolling that has ever been done to
me there was an article that said I was
guilty of bestiality oh said wolf guilty
of bestiality and it was from my
hometown newspaper the homeless town Sun
and which is a very small newspaper
there's like three or four people that
work there I think but like it said that
I was guilty of bestiality and they did
so much research like they got they got
like the paper the right paper they got
like all this information about me and
then the surprising thing was at the
editor article it said I pled guilty and
the fine was 15
hundred dollars and I was like it was it
was about [ __ ] dogs that I was
[ __ ] dogs and I was like well if that
was what I was into fifteen hundred
dollars like it's kind of worth it how
much money you have and how big the
dog's dick is yeah and I was also like
how is the dog is the dog [ __ ] me
what is it like a peanut butter
situation I think there's videos like
that that existed before the internet
there was a video like thing was called
barnyard Betty as me my friend Billy and
my friend Ron we went over their house
and it was in the basement I remember
one of us had a guard the door okay
someone came into the basement was old
VHS tape so they put they put the VHS
tape on and one of us has stand by the
doorway to the basement it's just to
make sure that nobody opened the door
him busted us and we watched this
fucked-up video of these trailer trash
looking meth girls that were blowing
donkeys and having sex with dogs one of
them had sex with a German Shepherd it
was so gross there was an episode of
nip/tuck where that happens like Klara's
remember that show there was a woman she
put like peanut butter on her vagina and
their dog would like lick it off oh
that's real that happens all the time
yeah and I was like I was like this is I
remember I was kind of younger and I was
like that's a weird thing to put in TV
with a dog bites yeah well I don't like
chomp
yeah I was getting greedy this seems
like a dangerous situation yeah if you
had too many dogs like you said like Oh
one's not enough I wouldn't want to
[Applause]